on va faire un petit prétoire pascal
obispo pascal obispo et c'est très
simple des questions chroniqueur sur
vous si c'est la bonne réponse pas de
souci c'est que ce n'est pas la bonne
réponse souci c'est quoi les soucis et
les soucis sont pour toi non c'est pas
ça
non ceci n'est pas mon cas les réponses
et les chroniqueurs attention vrai ou
faux
le titre je suis tombé pour elle devait
s'appeler j'ai vu jérusalem j'ai vu
jérusalem c'est faux j'ai vu jérusalem
ça donnait ça fait séduit chez les
messieurs les pour une télé part de mon
premier album à jérusalem oui et j'ai
adoré la ville est en fête au moment
d'enregistrer on m'a déconseillé et dont
on m'a conseillé plus tôt de parler de
choses que je connaissais vraiment et
donc je me suis recentré sur les cabanes
tchanquées qui sont exactement au milieu
entre la maison de bernard il est la
mienne je suis tombé pour elle vrai ou
faux pascal obispo a déjà fait bercy
déguisé en reine des neiges
je vais dire oui c'est vrai il a encore
michael gregorio sur la scène de bercy
déguisé en alsace de l'arête dnc faux
ona l'express et faut aussi regarder les
images
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non les artistes anglais que j'adore
était un peu transformés tu vois comme
david bowie etc
voilà donc en france c'est pas ça fait
pas le même effet mais moi j'aime bien
ça tout ça j'aime bien j'aime bien un
peu de second degré ça c'est bien
jean-michel merveilleux ou faux pascal
obispo à chanter le générique de sous le
soleil
c'est rigoureusement exact c'est
rigoureusement exact alors alors alors
c'est quoi alors c'est quoi
on sait maintenant
regardez côté de ce lait
lui qui change c'est la douce et a dit
martial yaya débat la tuer mais c'est
lui qui a composé
[Applaudissements]
vous faites une nouvelle émission la
nouvelle chose qui se passe c'est la
plus belle chose que tu connais bien
c'est vrai c'est une invitation
quatrième question pour vous prenez un
faux pascal obispo a écrit une chanson
pour lionel richie
oh c'est vrai ça oh c'est vrai ça c'est
le crooner qui parle
et oui ça s'appelle il s'agit de eye for
god absolument pas je n'ai pas écrit
pour lui je l'écris pour moi il en a
fait une cover donc c'est fou alors là
ça parce que j'ai jamais écrit de
chansons pour lionel richie je sais à
peine qui sait bon attention gilles
verdez vrai ou faux pascal obispo écrit
l'hymne eu des girondins de bordeaux son
club de foot préférée c'est vrai c'est
vrai alors vous êtes fans des girondins
de bordeaux
alors vous dites que c'est vrai bien sûr
gilles gilles c'est faux son papa était
joueur
oui girondins de bordeaux exactement à
57 et 61 aidé à gagner des trophées
voilà si simplement je sais que tu es un
grand fan de foot rend fans de foot
l'acte a soutenu l'équipe de france à
fond du type de france la soutient tout
le temps je sais lui-même sata énervé
qu'on y avait quelques critiques sur
l'équipe de france
ah oui tout de suite raison oui parce
qu'au début tout le monde doutait un peu
de la capacité un peu énervé mais j'ai
balancé un peu assez rare de m'apparaît
mais j'ai ballon enceinte a bien fait de
the way des choses parce que je trouve
ça incroyable de pas les laisser
tranquilles il faut toujours critiquer
ici mais non et je voudrais vous dire
été jusqu'au bout et bravo d'aidé et les
travaux
c'est l'anniversaire du des échanges de
vues en 3 de bones anniversaire j'ai la
chance de connaître quelques joueurs de
l'équipe de france j'ai encore eu
olivier giroud ce week-end au téléphone
qui rameix exceptionnel vraiment voilà
je vous le dis ils sont tous formidables
vraiment lukas hernandez 1 intègre des
mecs aiment bape est aussi franchement
je vous le dis toute l'équipe
bon bien sûr a dit il tous m'ont
griezmann antoine sa maman est vraiment
c'est des mecs bien tous ils n'ont pas
pris la grosse tête bonne bande vrai
c'est vraiment notre très solidaire est
sur les nerfs pour ça qu'ils ont gagné
une colo kanté sagma aussi qui vous avez
reçu un puck man show vous allez rester
comme ça tu votes nous faut les chansons
tu trouveras chanter et sa raison d'être
est écrite à l'origine pour véronique
sanson vrai ou faux et font c'est faux
c'est faux c'était pour france gall
exact et si fou ça et elle a refusé
finalement ses chansons c'est là qu'elle
a refusé je pense que c'était de jouer
je pense que c'était difficile de faire
des chansons après l'illustrent michel
berger mais on m'avait posé la question
aussi finalement je les fais en sachant
un peu la réponse mais c'est vrai que
toutes ces chansons étaient étaient
écrites pour france sa raison d'être
c'est 1,3 tube énorme on les écoute
regardez bien sûr on avait sa raison de
sa raison d'être
on avait ça
sa région oui mais séparément de sa
région
chanter chanter de la dore passé c'est
pascal qui chantait pour oublier ses pas
k
les pièces et poirier
bon
comment les pézilla
chanter sans s'arrêter je suis fan à mes
fans